bueno
[Música]
hola y bienvenidos aquí américa el
espacio de france 24 para revisar en
profundidad los hechos más importantes
del continente esta semana yo soy andrés
meza en reemplazo de natalia cabrera y
estos son nuestros titulares eeuu tiene
un nuevo feriado el jumping el día que
conmemora el fin de la esclavitud en la
unión americana el 19 de junio de 1865
un reclamo histórico que tomó impulso
con el auge del movimiento black lights
matters las vidas de los negros importan
en 2020 tras el asesinato de georges
floyd en minneapolis y una plaga se tomó
a eeuu con un canto incesante que
emergió de la tierra es la temporada de
cigarras una vez más en el país
norteamericano un extraño fenómeno que
sucede sólo una vez cada 17 años
y una ola de detenciones de opositores
en nicaragua despierta la preocupación
de la comunidad internacional más de 16
personas han sido arrestadas entre ellas
4 candidatos presidenciales a las
elecciones de noviembre de este año en
la que el presidente daniel ortega quien
ha estado en el poder durante 15 años
busca una nueva reelección y vamos de
inmediato al norte del continente en
eeuu para nuestra historia principal
desde 1866 cada 19 de junio los
afroestadounidenses celebran lo que se
conocía como el día del jubileo o de la
libertad con oraciones música y comida
una fiesta que nació en texas pero que
se propagó por todo el país a medida que
la comunidad se trasladaba a lo largo y
ancho del país hasta ahora sólo 48
estados de los 50 que componen la unión
lo reconocían como un feriado estatal o
día para recordar este mes el senado y
la cámara de representantes le dieron el
visto bueno por lo que se convirtió a la
ley tras la firma del presidente joe
biden así nació young tim también
conocido como el día de la independencia
negra un feriado federal para
demorar la emancipación de los
afroamericanos esclavizados
eeuu celebra ahora el giuntini
[Música]
un nuevo festivo para conmemorar el día
en el que los últimos esclavos fueron
liberados en texas en 1865 y que quedó
marcado como el día en el que la
esclavitud fue abolida por completo en
la unión americana dos años y medio
después de que abraham lincoln emitiera
la proclamación de emancipación se trata
de un juego de palabras entre hyung
junio en inglés y la fecha 19 night in
hemos llegado lejos pero aún tenemos que
ir muy lejos pero hoy es un día de
celebración no sólo un día de orgullo
y para reafirmar y dedicarnos nuevamente
a la acción y con eso digo feliz yantín
a todos los padres el nuevo feriado
llega tras la aprobación en la cámara de
representantes del proyecto y la
posterior firma del presidente yo bailé
este es un día en mi opinión de profundo
peso y profundo poder de wii
un día en el que recordamos la mancha
moral el terrible precio que la
esclavitud tomó en el país y continúa
causando lo que durante mucho tiempo he
llamado el pecado original de eeuu
el blanco
también recuerdo la extraordinaria
capacidad de sanar de tener esperanza y
de salir de sus momentos dolorosos y una
versión amarga amarga de nosotros mismos
solo 14 representantes votaron en contra
todos republicanos la comunidad afro en
eeuu venía celebrando esta fecha
accesible pero su discusión en el
capitolio tomó impulso tras el asesinato
de george cloud en mayo de 2020 por el
policía blanco terex saving mientras él
gritaba no puedo respirar una frase que
se convirtió en insignia del movimiento
black light soft mata las vidas de los
negros importa que se tomó el país en
protestas en contra del racismo
estructural y logró cambios en varios
ámbitos desde el deportivo hasta el
social
y los gobernadores de todo el país se
apresuraron para darle el libre el
viernes a todos los empleados federales
pero más allá de un día libre en el
verano la historia del txupin también
conocido como el día de la independencia
negra se va a enseñar en todas las
escuelas a todos por igual sigamos en
eeuu con la imagen de la semana el
presidente joe biden se reunió con su
homólogo ruso vladimir putin para su
primer cara a cara en ginebra ambos
entraron en la cita con muchos
desacuerdos por lo que fueron escasos
los avances concretos sin embargo
anunciaron la restitución de los
embajadores en las respectivas capitales
llamados a consultas desde marzo de 2020
por la injerencia rusa en las elecciones
presidenciales estadounidenses del año
pasado además acordaron dialogar sobre
el control a las armas nucleares
concordando en que ninguno podría
superar al otro en una guerra un avance
para una relación difícil marcada por
las críticas de washington a la
detención del opositor ruso alexéi
navalni y la anexión rusa del territorio
ucraniano de crimea entre otros
y hay una invasión masiva de zombis en
eeuu y no estoy hablando de una película
de hollywood hablo de cigarras
específicamente de la especie brutten
que son conocidas como cigarras zombies
porque tienen un destacado ciclo de vida
pasan 17 años bajo tierra y luego
emergen de ella en una espantosa manada
que a pesar de su apariencia es
inofensiva ya que nos destruye cultivos
pero si puede generar accidentes de
tránsito veamos más en el siguiente
informe
una cigarra aterriza en el cuello del
presidente bai ling cuando se dirige de
eeuu a europa se la quitó con un
manotazo y cayó al suelo
sin embargo el equipo de prensa tuvo
problemas más importantes su avión se
retrasó varias horas debido a un
enjambre de cigarras una especie llamada
brought team que sólo se encuentra en
eeuu cada insecto crece hasta unos cinco
centímetros de largo a pesar de su
apariencia son inofensivos
se les llama cigarras zombies porque
pasan 17 años bajo tierra antes de
emerger para vivir un período de varias
semanas
al emerger uno a la vez entre los miles
de millones que puede ser incluso un
billón garantizan que no hay suficientes
depredadores en ningún momento para
comerlos todos las cigarras brokking
comenzaron a proliferar el mes pasado en
15 estados desde georgia hasta
washington dc y en el oeste hasta
indiana e illinois si bien tienen
facilidad para reproducirse ese no es el
caso en este parque en long island en el
estado de nueva york donde surgieron
pocas los entomólogos están preocupados
por las cigarras porque podrían haber
desaparecido por completo debido a una
serie de factores vivientes concretos
sobre una superficie eso prácticamente
las matas la tala de árboles y el
desarrollo les quita su fuente de
alimento además la introducción de
muchos depredadores como gorriones y
estorninos que se alimentan de ellos por
las mentes han reducido las poblaciones
hay un cierto umbral crítico que tienen
a pesar de que son tan abundantes que si
cae por debajo de ese umbral la podría
condenar
la cigarra zombies de este año perforar
en el suelo para resurgir en 2038
no amenazan los cultivos pero su gran
número puede tomar a la gente por
sorpresa causando accidentes
automovilísticos por ejemplo
algunos las ven como un buen almuerzo a
la parrilla o es útil
revisemos otras noticias destacadas de
las américas esta semana por tercera vez
el llamado obama care la ley que amplía
la cobertura de salud para millones de
personas recibió el apoyo de la corte
suprema de eeuu el tribunal desestimó la
demanda interpuesta por texas y otros 17
estados conservadores que argumentaban
que ciertos aspectos de la iniciativa de
salud asequible del ex presidente barack
obama son inconstitucionales el
organismo electoral de perú finalizó el
conteo de votos de las elecciones
presidenciales del 6 de junio dándole
una estrecha ventaja al candidato de
izquierda pedro castillo sobre la
conservadora keiko fujimori sin embargo
no puede ser declarado ganador hasta que
no se terminen de revisar las
apelaciones a las actas presentadas por
la hija del ex presidente alberto
fujimori quien fue condenado por delitos
de lesa humanidad
en colombia el comité nacional del paro
suspendió temporalmente las
manifestaciones antigubernamentales
sosteniendo que busca poner fin a las
muertes de jóvenes a manos de la policía
y que el gobierno de iván duque no tiene
intención de dialogar según
organizaciones internacionales
defensoras de los derechos humanos como
human rightswatch al menos 20 personas
han muerto desde el inicio de las
protestas el 28 de abril por abusos de
la fuerza pública
y las víctimas de la dictadura uruguaya
declararon ante la corte interamericana
de derechos humanos y pidieron justicia
por las desapariciones forzadas y
ejecuciones extrajudiciales perpetradas
hace 50 años por parte de agentes
estatales hasta ahora ninguna persona ha
sido condenada por los casos
y vamos a nicaragua para revisar la
cifra de la semana 4 este es el número
de candidatos presidenciales
nicaragüenses detenidos de cara a las
elecciones del 7 de noviembre en las que
el presidente daniel ortega aspira a ser
reelegido por tercera vez para otro
mandato de cinco años con el cual
completaría 20 años en el poder se trata
de cristiana chamorro arturo cruz félix
maradiaga y juan sebastián chamorro más
de una quincena de personas han sido
detenidas en una ola de persecución que
ha despertado la preocupación de la
comunidad internacional esta semana la
organización de estados américanos firmó
una resolución pidiendo la liberación de
todos los presos políticos a la que sólo
se opusieron la propia nicaragua bolivia
y san vicente y las granadinas pero para
la que se abstuvieron méxico-argentina
honduras belice y dominica las
detenciones se han llevado a cabo bajo
la llamada ley de soberanía que persigue
a los que llama traidores a la patria
revisemos en qué consiste esta
legislación
en diciembre de 2020 la asamblea
nacional aprobó la ley 10 55 conocida
como la ley de soberanía una iniciativa
que asegura buscar la defensa de los
derechos del pueblo a la independencia
la soberanía y la autodeterminación para
la paz y tipifica como crimen la
traición a la patria un delito de amplio
espectro la ley dice que es todo aquel
que financió un golpe de estado fomente
actos terroristas o que inciten a la
injerencia extranjera demande o aplauda
la imposición de sanciones contra
nicaragua también incluye a quienes
pidan intervenciones militares y
bloqueos económicos en contra del país
hace parte de un paquete legislativo que
incluye a la ley de regulación de
agentes extranjeros que divide a los
ciudadanos entre verdaderos
nicaragüenses y agentes extranjeros a la
ley de ciberdelitos conocida como la ley
mordaza por limitar el contenido en
internet y criminalizar el ejercicio
periodístico
el objetivo es limpiar la cancha y
presentarse finalmente a unas elecciones
presidenciales el 7 de noviembre sin que
exista un competidor
que sea capaz de derrotar a ortega el
paquete legislativo también incluye una
reforma que amplía de 48 horas a 90 días
el tiempo de detención durante la
investigación los hasta ahora detenidos
son acusados de delitos supuestamente
cometidos antes de la promulgación de la
ley lo que según decenas de abogados es
además inconstitucional pues las leyes
no son retroactivas por lo que
presentaron varios recursos de apelación
ante la corte suprema de justicia que ya
anteriormente ha demostrado estar a
favor de ortega como en 2009 cuando
admitió el recurso del presidente
aspirar a la reelección de 2011 tras
meses de incertidumbre y cambios de sede
finalmente comenzó la copa américa la
competencia de fútbol más antigua del
mundo el torneo iba a disputarse en dos
sedes colombia y argentina pero debido a
la ola de protestas en colombia el país
cafetero pidió el aplazamiento del
torneo a la conmebol lo que la
confederación sudamericana de fútbol
negó posteriormente el organismo dijo
que argentina tampoco podía ser el
anfitrión del evento deportivo debido a
la situación que se vive en el país
austral por la pandemia paradójicamente
la otorgó
brasil el país más afectado de
suramérica por el cobe 19
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa yo soy andrés meza muñoz
y en esta producción participaron andrés
doncel y natalia cabrera recuerde que
puede ver este y otros programas en
france24 punto com